congress plans to address the national
baby formula shortage in a hearing later
this month but for parents the problem
is urgent and they want action right now
one research firm says 43 of formula
sellers are now out of stock that's up
from 31 percent in early april now part
of the problem is a major recall from
abbott that was announced in february
and later expanded over concerns of
bacteria at its largest formula
manufacturing plant that's located in
michigan now certain formulas of similac
we know that alimentum and elega elegant
elegant care ella care
how do you say it tony ella care ella
carolyn ella care i'm not familiar with
this when ella care were affected abbott
is the leading supplier of more of milk
formula in this country our consumer
investigative correspondent anna warner
has been talking to some very frustrated
parents
she she's a fighter
she's a warrior five-month-old mackenzie
janer was born three months early
spending more than a hundred days in the
nicu and now needs formula designed for
premature babies but parents emily and
max say it's been a struggle to find
each morning max says he drives to at
least five grocery stores in three
separate counties searching and you turn
the corner into into the baby food and
formula aisle and it's just absolutely
barren the couple even has family and
friends sending them cans from other
states formula is the only thing that's
going to get mackenzie healthy supply
chain issues and a major recall have
meant empty shelves and shortages across
major manufacturers but one baby formula
manufacturer that is not experiencing a
shortage is this one pennsylvania-based
buy heart their product launched in
march the company says the baby formula
is made with clean ingredients and based
on the latest nutrition research
vihart's co-founders are brother and
sister bob beldergrin and mia funt
we worked with the world's experts
in breast milk research to get closer
than ever before to breast milk they
started their company five years ago but
couldn't know that their product would
land in the middle of a nationwide
shortage now their online only sales are
booming i'll tell you in just the first
six days
we sold into all 50 states
that was really shocking to us
already they're adding another shift at
their plant so they can run 24 7.
are you guys able to keep up with the
demand
at this point we are in good shape he
says in large part because they control
their own supply chain and don't
outsource production manufacturer abbott
whose supply has been impacted by its
recall of multiple baby formulas and a
shutdown of its michigan plant says it's
working to increase its supplies at
other facilities meanwhile at bihart the
co-founders say
we have a responsibility to to show up
and help the industry to help parents
we mentioned abbott given the shortage
the fda is now allowing limited
distribution of unaffected formulas from
abbott's michigan plant gerber and
enfamil's parent company reckett didn't
respond to our requests for comment on
this situation the cdc says speak with
your child's doctor or nurse before
switching your baby's formula brand or
type and the fda warns against making
homemade infant formula they say it
could lead to serious health problems
for your baby yeah that's a dicey
maneuver some people sent me some
recipes and i was like i'm not going to
try this well it's difficult and
time-consuming for a lot of parents i
think it's unrealistic it's very risky i
didn't know about this buy heart company
though yeah they say their sales are
booming they went live seven weeks ago
and right in the middle of the shortage
yeah so you can imagine
online only but i love that it's a
brother-sister combo isn't that neat
yeah i like that yeah they came up with
it like five years ago and they were
kind of working in related fields and he
said you know i feel like there's
something we could do here and they did
it nice
hopefully that can alleviate some of the
stress of some of these new parents
that's for sure anna thank you so much